she's the mayor of camden i'm the mayor
of chicago welcome to how neal field
hey guys just started the clock
i have a timer that i have that i think
the batteries love so it's a little
faint
um all right expand it to bianca um
bianca do you remember your week i do
and
you know i don't know i'm afraid it's
gonna suck you're gonna do like
book reports on your week now that i've
asked you to
know something i'm just gonna pick a
highlight and something
something not good happened and i have
to tell you about it ooh
it's so well quickly we both got facts
quickly it was not interesting
we held each other's hands the whole
time not interesting
yeah uh it was done happy i did it i'm
never skeptic and
it's done and will's done too don't ask
don't
guys don't ask no further questions
everyone can get it if you don't
you're not a tuesday listener if you
don't get the vaccine
how about that you can understand that's
almost true
you're we don't want you for the podcast
if you don't get the vaccine
anyhow tell me the bad thing tell me
show me on the week where the bad thing
happened
can i tell you though in my head i keep
singing 311
all maxed up don't know what to do
okay very nice so dude
you know we talked about the other day
if you um
are like a street superhero like if how
what
level would you go to like stop
something yes
well i proved i from the podcast torn
ripped from the pod uh so i was walking
minding my own business in uh the
greatest place in la
dtla and so there's a huge homeless
issue in downtown to life
no one knew that there's like skid row
and that's rolled pretty well known
it's pretty relatable the population's
around 30 i don't know if it's 35 000
it's something it's a
gargantuan amount bigger than a random
like a regular
town in middle america what does that
say 4 700. but that's got to be that's
before
that's the census that's before
covets the difference with covet they
don't push people off the street
so that's why all these people are by my
house too they you're allowed to stay
all day right and so so
justice at the same time do it myself
you get him i put up a thing a snowplow
on the front of my prius i'm in the
front of my i don't have a breath in
front of my
tesla i tell myself it's free make
myself sleep better at night
and i push homeless people i push all
their stuff
anyhow you were saying um so the
situation in the
defense of the reality it's terrible
it's disgusting
yeah they i think during covert they
stopped sanitation so they actually had
cleanup and sanitation that had routes
through homeless encampments so
the homeless would give them their trash
they would move their tents
or whatever their setup is and they
would clean it
so there was some level of cleanliness
down there even though it's
it can get a little tough at in some
parts of downtown
that being said okay so that
whatever so i'm walking there's a guy
tall
white with a cell phone i thought and
then there's somebody on the ground i
thought it was a photo shoot for some
reason because it's la
i thought it was influenced
and there's a guy on the floor
tweaking just homeless no shoes
no underwear on kind of a weird wrap
like a weird scarf lace thing
and he's tweaking out of his mind he
doesn't know what planet he's on he's
full ayahuasca
and
and so uh this guy's
video recording him and laughing i like
i
just could not just walk by that it was
so
gross i mean he was just i don't know
probably two feet
away from him and like cracking up yeah
i don't know people who do this and the
other person also wasn't
uh going through anything he just seemed
like a regular guy and there's none of
these people
were from jackass no okay there's no
stevo inside
okay um so
that's very funny so i'm standing behind
him
and i just say very calmly i was like is
that
really funny like because on just
straight up
it wasn't funny at all you know uh
and then that that really that was
that was it was on he was like yeah it's
funny it's hilarious i'm like
it's hilarious to exploit this guy on
the floor that is
the guy with the phone homeless no he
was just like a regular
white guy with a group of friends eating
night or day
day like 1 p.m and they were all
doing some like street taco pop-up
hipsters yep uh young
no this isn't some old white army
veteran
right and so i was like is it
is it is it funny to exploit this guy i
mean that is clearly going through
something he's like
he did it to himself i didn't do this to
him it's hilarious
like and then it got then he just
well then you're just arguing comedy
semantics at that point
so of course it got like he was so upset
he's like don't talk [ __ ] to me you get
in my face i'm like okay i'm not getting
in your face and i saw i walk away right
so i go up to my friend's apartment and
i told her what happened she was like
no no we gotta go back down there like i
don't know if it's a good idea
i gotta hit the hit the toilet real
quick
i was like i don't think that's a good
idea she was like no [ __ ] that
no he got on your face we're gonna go
down there so we go back down there
he's not there but his friends were and
we just had a conversation with them
like
why wouldn't anybody say anything right
they were like we saw you get in his
face like regardless of that
he's taking a photo of a homeless guy on
drugs tweaking
rolling on the ground no everybody
thought that was
cool yeah and the guy who set it up said
well people need to know what's going on
down here and
you know that guy did it to himself and
and
you you don't understand it's like this
i don't appreciate seeing his
balls i'm like uh yeah it was the most
defensive
but not really i just defensive because
no one wanted to agree with me because
it was their friend
so we were the guy friend was gone and
they were still i was gone they were
like you're
in his you're wrong and then they're
bringing about awareness
this is an awareness campaign for
exposed balls
and mental illness and so all of us at
some point i mean it wasn't
when it was the friends it was whatever
but me and my friends are just like
i didn't factor in all of you would be
fine with it yeah
i thought this was like a rogue guy
doing something weird
yeah and for all of them to be had
they thought we were crazy yeah
was the homeless guy white he was brown
not black
and not white and he mind he was still
rolling on the ground when he went back
so german panamanian
and iranian he was my brother
um no it was just so strange i think we
assign
like that level of ignorance to old
why i assign it to
uh like extras in a movie they sound
like extras like
no man he did it to himself
like he did himself i'm like i guess if
you want to
get deep with it yeah fine so what
so yeah you only have empathy
if they didn't do it to themselves okay
i mean yeah i just was like oh
so none of you care yeah and they're
like no he he was within his right
whatever the same arguments yeah and
then we're like i think
we're done here great you tried to be a
hero
didn't you you were a little bit of a
hero you met with some resistance
and then i don't know if it would if
that was a
if that if that's bianca number one
the comic book that would not be issue
number one
that's if that's issue number one i
don't know if it's a collector's edition
storytelling wise it isn't the greatest
art it just was very weird to me to see
hipstery types yeah everyone's people
that
you would think were white liberals or
not right and uh
like i'm sure march for black lives
matter like it just
when you realize it's like it's
performative at every level
like even but i would say even that's
performative what video
because it's like they want to post it
somewhere it's like
now i'm an influencer before i was a uh
activist now i'm about content i'm a
creator
but also i was the only person on the
street saying something
so right i don't know was it a crowded
street
yeah so i don't like
do i mind my own business i mean i
definitely got
in a thing with someone so
i don't know you're better you're better
than them
i can't believe it get right out of boy
bart came in oh speaking of
white bird another thing happened i went
to this new restaurant called chifa
chifa it's really good you can't eat
anything there but uh
i think they have i'm on my way they
have a they have a corn dish
um you [ __ ]
anyways uh someone yelled at me
attaboy bert but they yelled it so loud
again that's a that's a good
that's welcome to fame my good woman and
guess what's
hilarious usher was there yet i'm the
only one who got yelled at
so they call me bi
hmm um why what did you do did you do
anything
on my level uh did i save
um i didn't save i didn't pseudo save
anybody did you count
i did stop filming a bunch but it's i
started i just yelled cut on the
commercial i was directing
is that that's convertible what did you
say absolutely
yeah thank you uh i did a bunch of
kevin hart chase stuff and um
i here's what happened i had to get up
at 6 00 a.m
uh i woke up in the sixes today as well
and my body don't like it
literally my eyes are watering i don't
even know what's happening
like i just my body's it's like a kidney
my body's rejecting you get up within
the nines
tens yeah i get up in the nights i'm up
there in the night
um yeah so i had to get up in the at
six and then in the sixes today does
that make
does that make uh like for a bad day or
you shake it off
no because i can't really be like oh
stupid
uh but it's not nothing funny happens
before
you know do you call do you do coffee no
i do my pills
huh my caffeine pills why do you the one
that i eat
because i don't like the taste of coffee
oh but you you eat caffeine pills yeah
like what's her name from say by the
bell oh yeah remember and then she
started
and she could open the jar right now
didn't i
again um too old you know it's funny
there was a
i have this book it's really it's
actually really cool it's called the big
book of drugs and it's just a bunch of
each page is like one or two dedicated
to like a bunch of different drugs
different research studies on different
drugs
whatever um and there was a study that
they gave lab rats the same
like the same amount but of caffeine a
day
a little bit like a little daily dose of
caffeine and the other
the other uh sample of lab rats
the same amount of cocaine and after 30
days
all the caffeine rats were dead
well i'm going on probably my 30th year
of caffeine
are you like i've never been more alive
i'm earning uh to quote the commercials
i've been shooting all day
i'm already i'm getting three percent
cash you're getting paid for that cash
back on
every purchase um they were
yesterday kevin was leaving they're like
kev we need just a little more audio and
he goes i swear to god
this is about three percent cash back
i'm [ __ ] walking
sure enough um uh
kevin hart is a funny good guy
does he make the set fun yeah i mean
it's fun
yeah he's fun because it's like there's
a movie star here but he's also just
like
you know a little crowd working it's not
like
it's not just yeah it's not like we're
here we're here
i've had to introduce people
i've had to introduce stars to the
people they're in scenes with after a
few takes
oh my god because they just got like
they don't
yeah but kev like knows they there's
what's funny is there's a bunch of
stand-ins
who have to we have to do lighting
kevin's skin tone and height
so there's like some five-five dudes in
l.a
that live off of kevin that's so funny
and
but he's like all right get like kind of
he knows him yeah
because there's only a few of them right
one of them was kevin's going to do a
movie in a foreign country and he was
he's like i was going to go but they
have one over there they have
a kevin a little kev look here yeah
you know what's funny when i didn't know
this but in germany
i realized that um in the countries that
dub
you like one voice over person is
assigned to every actor and
you're like your career it's almost like
you can't
hide it's tied to that person because
now that's your voice it doesn't switch
so
apparently this is a funny story so
apparently the guy who did
eddie murphy's voice died so
he they got somebody else but everyone's
like eddie
that's funny it's so funny so oh so a
little something a little tip a little
hollywood tip
from bianca um
anyhow bianca the earth the world is not
it's not doing any better or worse than
it was last week i don't think
uh george floyd as we're recording they
just
went into deliberations right and i feel
like it's got to be a couple days
because there's three charges
and you know is it i know apparently
jury like the jury system is generally
pretty good
like that's not where the corruption is
in the justice system but
that it's a lot for people that don't
have
law degrees yeah well they're like wait
what i think it's a lot of like it's
but it's really regular it's you and
you get on the bus today you and 12
decis
12 people have to 11 put in the
alternate
uh had to have to adjudicate murder
with a law enforcement and a law
enforcement official
and a person it's basically like you
yeah so they so i mean you hear about it
where people are like
wait now okay
what is and then like and it's terms
that an educated person manslaughter
it's like
okay well what's that right when you
look at the yeah
but it can't be involuntary premeditated
aggressive like just words that it's i
don't
i send them love and light everyone is
my point i hate to call for love and
life
you know what you know what this calls
for love in the night
um uh do you have you ever been on
you've been around for a while
no i've been to the premiere
read it uh read the script wait
um went to bowfinger oh my god
it's beaufinger uh yes norbit i
was considered to direct that's how old
i am
i love how so uh anyhow but
never gone to been never again never
been picked
you've gone to the yeah i no i've never
even gone i just
call in and then cancel for a journey
have you gone
no well i don't i don't think i was
registered until pretty recently
yeah so i think i've been up twice
in like a fairly short of like four
years like twice guys
okay um and uh
but the funny thing about
the chauvin about the defense
the things they've tried are like uh
well it could have been carbon monoxide
poisoning was the car
because of the well i don't know i
didn't check was there carbon monoxide
in his blood we didn't check for that
either
why are you talking about this it was a
hybrid okay
if you don't know if the car's on then
you don't know
they could have said you know he i think
he has blacktop poisoning
he got gravel in his throat like well
he's down there by the ground why not
he has gutter poisoning this guy did
them in this guy did them india
the that's also the kind of guy
if you're him and you're sitting on the
plane and someone goes what do you do
for work you go
i'm a shoe salesman because you don't go
i'm uh
i'm a medical i'm a former medical
examiner where are you going minnesota
what for
ah it's not important yeah like yeah
like i
i i don't want to talk about it like i'm
not much of a talker
honestly if i could just read my
magazine where are my beats by dre
yeah the [ __ ] that they think did you
see the aliens
was that it was such a terrible argument
he was basically
saying defining reasonable doubt
he's like aliens could have come down
into derek shovin
and that's what that is the reason why
he
did that maybe it was aliens now of
course it
wasn't aliens but the defense
look up derrick shove and defense i mean
i believe you i don't want to watch
these people no no no
not to watch it but the he has it's like
a two cent
it's so yeah uh
that's fanciful uh yeah
yeah like or he had a heart attack
that's the other thing like hey just
it's like what are the odds some
that's when the extraneous [ __ ] happened
when prosecutors showed
every day he was alive with all the
conditions they talked about
and somehow and then they're like this
was the only day he
wasn't alive what's different about this
day if you had to show me a tape
um and then maxine waters you see what
happened with her
no she okay so basically the judge
in the case oh um i uh
i what my time no yeah i yield my ti i
i whatever reclaim i reclaim my time but
she's at it again
not as well this time not as catchy this
time what
basically she said she went to minnesota
um and she said at a uh
we she said to a bunch of activists
we've got to stay in the street and
we've got to get more active
we've got to get more confrontational
we've got to make sure they know we mean
business
the judge said that may be jury
tampering
think about all the [ __ ] they said about
before january 6
and after january 6 and they were the
jury
right and somehow that's not tampering
but this is
this may be just protesters yes
not to the jury no no she just said it
on the street
four jurists were driving by
um yeah what did the odds they even
heard it so now they're saying
they may have grounds for a retrial are
you [ __ ] kidding me on what
what what about that jury tampering but
what you can just just say
that's if a if a high-profile elected
official
says something specific like basically
intimidation like
if you don't find this man guilty
we're going to be in your face we're
going to be confrontational and we mean
business but the funny thing is after
dante wright the judge ordered them to
not they are not allowed to watch the
news so
oh yeah i don't think they're yeah after
the dante like hey maybe now's the time
to
cut the news i'm sure you're getting
good even-handed stuff right
until now there's not everything really
through the the news for a loop
uh yeah so i hope to god
um he asked the the chauvin's lawyer
asked for a mistrial
and uh he denied the request but said
that
water's comments were aberrant or
abhorrent
and uh and that she may have handed the
defensive lifeline anyway
but i think the people protesting are
how are they not jury tampering right
there's also
uh opposition there's also people
everybody's commented on this
right so but that's why
politicians are supposed to say um due
process
and they're let's go to trial and
nothing else they're not president
or yeah not void where prohibited
um now dante wright i have continued
what
down i don't know it's just awful it
happened
it was new last week when it happened
but to them to my
stop asian hate point
america's got a real [ __ ] violence
problem
by witnessed by that by the fedex shoot
there's shootings there's mass shootings
every
day every day to the point where
i don't know if i'm i'm like paranoid
but i went to
mendocino farms the other day so right
there
so it's a pretty great story already and
i was just thinking of gunman coming in
of like what i would do and it's got to
get to the point where
there's one every day oh i don't like if
someone's
running i was i think maybe last
before the pandemic i flew somewhere i
think miami or something
and there was a lady people were i'm in
the airport
people running and screaming and no
laughter
and i'm sitting there like oh my god was
there a sale of some kind
you know at the same time i don't know
so
they're just running screaming i'm like
okay cool
there's someone has a gun so there's a
map of the mass shootings is that a map
of the mass shootings or covet outbreaks
you tell me yeah no of course that's the
mass shootings because we're good
but anyways there was a [ __ ] rat
the lady was like shooing right but i
just remember thinking like not the
problem right now
but yeah yeah but i just mean the moment
i saw screaming and
you assume anywhere if anyone's
screaming and running um
there's someone has a gun i was gonna
tweet but i didn't tweet it because it
would obviously
is i'm being sarcastic and you know no
one will get it no
but i was going to say who's in more
danger in america
a black man dealing with a cop or an
american dealing with an american
because it's [ __ ] it's good i know
it's too it's a little
too like it's right on the thing am i
just no i'm no
g i would be right but i'm making a
point that
the whole thing is too [ __ ] dangerous
it's just
and which another thing i wanted to talk
to we can talk about it now [ __ ] it
we'll talk about it let's do it
how do you police a nation with 300
million guns
without a gun that's the thing of like
the the best
you know without again what do you mean
you're saying for the police not having
guns
yeah if if the idea being that option
that right that like we'll just have
social workers go
and like i was saying one social worker
gets shot and that's the end of that
um then they're like maybe we'll just
give the social workers hand grenades
um um but
how do you police a crazy nation
[ __ ] crazy we are so weird to
everybody else
the amount i can only imagine i got to
think we have more guns than i don't
want to say the rest of the world
combined
but i got to think citizens wise
citizens why is 100
it's gotta of course we'll be in every
other country do we beat them all
combined
take off story off the map they don't
got any no take england off they don't
get it nobody has guns yeah
there's no i think central america and
africa have guns
but there's laws against it yeah still
you know like it's not like
everyday citizens outside of hunting so
every country although i don't know
you know what i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking i don't know who has guns
who has guns
who has guns the falklands my god
yemen there you go that's what i meant
so it's us by switching by double the
next
the falkland islands which i don't even
understand what that's based
on island's got 3 000 people 2 000 guns
that's don't even count it but that's
because i think there's military going
on there
we have more than one look mita look how
many firearms we have total
we have more unregistered yeah we have
more guns than people
it's [ __ ] crazy yemen thought
light and love half the population
go wait who has the least
australia show me australia iceland
island iceland
taiwan zero oh i forgot about all the
asian countries they do not play yeah
they sure don't
they i told you i had there was a bullet
in my
luggage when i was in china how'd that
go
how are you here i don't know i had a
bullet because
there was like this ammo because i went
to a gun range and i think it fell into
my
and then when i went there i was packing
i was like
like imagine trying no these aren't my
pants uh and then i was packing my stuff
because i really used to live there
and i'm like dude and he's like is that
a live
bullet mike dude that's alive what the
[ __ ] he's like
we gotta get rid of it me and my brother
that's what i understand like how did it
even get
i don't know what did i get through well
getting how did yeah how did it
i don't know but me and my brother there
was no one to calm anyone down yeah
we got into like an anxious tizzy we're
like he's like let's go to the river
shooting your brother from what i hear
we walk to a river we walk like an hour
to a river
and i'm like you thought you do it
anyway so they don't yeah i know
asian countries don't so this is that
next time someone brings up
guns and uh police force and all [ __ ]
it's like i
i don't this is so [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
the problem is that i understand why
cops
get very weary around people with guns
you know what i mean like i get it like
you're the bad guy you know what i mean
we're bi
but i don't think i we're talking about
shooting unarmed people
oh yeah no i'm but i'm just saying
there's also another problem with
there are also like there's so many guns
there's so many unregistered guns like
do you see a documentary i know a girl
who had a bullet on her didn't even know
it that's how many guns we have in
america
that's but that's telling yeah like i
yes there was a bullet alive anyways uh
do you do have you seen the documentary
i forgot the name
but um maybe it was like frontline or
something but it just said this this
cycle of guns
and how they get to um
you know well that's that's the all the
central and south american ones is
that's how
we're we [ __ ] them with yeah
unregistered guns and it's
it's an it's a nightmare i don't think i
can't imagine a way to
undo that i would have moved to hong
kong if the chinese didn't take it from
me what about
taiwan taiwan i hear good stuff i don't
think i love their climate the way i do
hong kong's climate it's it's a moisture
is it a moisture climate mm-hmm night
market we get a moisture
i'm moist i'm western thailand there's
my merch
climate of thailand is subtropical
except the very southern part of the
island which is tropical
that's where i'll be summers are long
and hot lasting from april or may to
september october
the winters are short and mild although
snow does fall on the mountaintops and
occasionally at lower elevations in the
north
okay so um see you there
i'll learn to [ __ ] it i'll learn
taiwanese um
[ __ ] it uh speaking of flying
west okay afghanistan that's east
rest in power king rest in power you
were
afghanistan you were right you did have
the time
we did have the watches you were right
there was a headline the other day uh
taliban chief says
they won and i was going to write like i
almost
never agree with the taliban but here
you go
i you got me buddy you they absolutely
won
losing losing we lost so many years ago
though
we lost before we went we lost in
[ __ ]
1980 we lost when russia left like
there's no
there's no winning there's
kathleen madigan the comedian one time
said that she went there and she was
like
it's a [ __ ] ass trick which is
she's just talking about the topography
it's it is a [ __ ] there's no
there's very few resources other than
the poppy there's no like
might there's just not a lot there well
where the
especially where they're stationed it's
obviously in deserts but there's a lot
of like lovely mountain ranges oh yeah
but i'm saying in terms of building an
economy
there's just not a ton there to like
resources
what can we sell uh these hats
what should we there's no education
there's no education infrastructure
there's just not a lot there
it's a it's a it's a you know
mineral field okay yeah i thought they
had a lot of 1400 minerals my
uncle works on the border of iran and
afghanistan and okay
they do a lot of mining okay does
afghanistan
uh oh wait that well that's too long an
article but
does afghanistan have rare earth or
minerals let's see what that says
uh 60 million metric tons of copper okay
well then build an economy jackasses i
think they do
have an aggregate i don't again the
people don't come here for good
information right i'm like
kneeling for every once in a while if
it's funny
great if it's true even greater but
that's not why we're here okay
uh now having said the no no go back go
back to the economy of afghanistan
uh steadily improved over the last
decade due to the return of large number
of wealthy expats the modernization of
the nation's agriculture sector 70
billion that's good
70 billion gdp for one person no it's a
gdp oh
so their their gdp is less profitable
than apple
their entire gdp i mean that's what i'm
saying it's more about
that's more about apple do you know what
i mean there's a lot of
of course 70 billions not i got to think
in terms of
uh the gdp over the over
everyone what's like every let's go
through gdp by country
well i don't want to jinx it but you're
doing great with these don't
i don't want to drink you know i don't
want to jinx it okay
united states number one of course uh
22 trillion china
16 trillion now you've got to go lower
it's not all right no but
okay so how far how far down afghanistan
number 115. i don't get it it says 19
billion here that's 19 yeah that's 19
billion
um yeah even less actually right
you got it well when you get to african
nations
russian power king tavalu
coming in at number 193 i've never heard
of the last four
no and tavalu those are two of my
favorite clubs actually
this is stupid um that's where i get
massages at no roo if you can't get in
at no room go to tavalo
um now so i
you know again one night maybe not so
bad if you got
[ __ ] you're occupied and you've got
war in government i don't know
but you you look you've got a thriving
economy afghanistan and party
um incredibly stupid
uh a worthless endeavor and almost
like a guy who said it he was gonna do a
thing and then
had to do it right and was like and was
like [ __ ] i said
by five o'clock all right we to invade
them and then they
the it was the whole they had
they could have got them in the in the
hindu kush they could have got them at
the
they there was a place where they they
didn't get them and then and he was in
pakistan the whole time
and right but after him i don't get why
i mean osama bin laden's been gone for a
long time so
too long as far as i'm going to go out
too soon
um what was the motivation you think
to keep it going because because they
were losing on so many minutes
because they've invested 4
000 dead soldiers and trillions of
dollars right
so much money and um sorry 2 300
dead soldiers uh ironically enough
almost the same exact amount as 9 11.
and um and how much money
it's un incalculable how much 2.4
trillion okay
so then the minute you leave
it just collapsed it's so funny how
people were so mad at 2
trillion to help
2.4 over what is it 25 people have no
i had the thought a couple years ago was
like i will never support another war
again
in my life have you ever world war ii
you know i was
at the premiere of i was at the premiere
of when hitler i used to
see hitler in the club
uh so a waste of time it's sunk cost
fallacy it's i
put in all this money so i have to keep
putting it in because it's gonna look
bad when i take it out
just rip the band-aid off [ __ ] it
by the way trump was gonna withdraw on
september 11th they were like we don't
like the optics and then
binds like september 11th that is like
did you not
just make it the 10th make it the first
first it's odd
to honor the people killed on 9 11
we're gonna make the war that we fought
in their name and i don't know
um it's so performative
it's all uh but we don't care about
anything that happened to them
afterwards but yes almost
everything's performative except eid of
sleeping and pooping
you heard that hair first in your life
in your life you will find that
everything in american life is
performative other than the involuntary
[ __ ]
and even some breathing is performative
some pooping could be performative
i mean that's a real niche market to
talk about
um johnson and johnson paused
their [ __ ] which uh i gotta say
um is one
one in a million person women were
getting
uh blood clots by the way someone
pointed out the amount
of women that get blood clots from birth
control that's literally astronomical
yeah the birth injury well
so it's so common yeah also we the
the things women do like uh the
amount of toxins that are not good for
women and they're like
tampons it has so much we have so many
side effects with things that go into
our bodies yeah uh dealing with our
reproductive system that
no one cares about i know i don't
am i right guys hi i'm neil brennan neil
does not perform
i i have three percent cashback it's
stupid
um yeah that's and then
the my other thought is are they
you know they're playing to the the
backs tonight they're playing to the
anti-vaxxers and going like
hey we're being safe and above board
about this
right so don't cut the [ __ ] and it's
like they're not gonna cut the [ __ ]
there's nothing you can do to make them
go you know what
these pharmaceutical companies are on
the up and up
there's no you know who i trust the
government and pharmaceuticals
yeah i was on a text about and some i
was just like
on the times rude but i said everyone i
know who's anti-vaxx has
zen copious amounts of cocaine you're
good
yeah like there's far more risk with the
drugs you guys do
and i don't get why you said it to them
or about them
no no to them in the direction what they
do they
there was a lot of dislikes like harsh
rebuke um
it's like being censured on the floor of
the capitol
it was a lot of dislikes and um
i was i said fear-mongering i was like
you're fear-mongering if you didn't care
about covid and the risks
that came with that i don't understand
why you know what
about any of the [ __ ] they take but
these are a lot of these people who are
saying see johnson johnson
also we're saying covet is not as big of
a zeal as ever
making it and the death rate of covet is
so much
greater than that yeah and the blood
clot
yeah the blood clot rate is higher and
the death so it's like
i usually don't say anything because i
don't
i just don't like when people push as
long as people aren't filming homeless
people you'll keep your mouth shut
but the minute they get rolling on a
homeless tweak
uh yeah do you have people who were
like see i told you no i don't
the dummies are mostly gone at this
point right
i don't i'm not i think maybe this is an
interesting question
who's got more
relationships with people they don't
really like men or women
i think weird i think men
interesting go because guys
just kind of are drama averse
like they're not like and then he said
so they
i feel like guys allow more bad behavior
in a way
yeah because that's the fighting thing
it's
the fighting thing and like we'll have
to fight you if i don't like your
coveted
and and like live and let live
kind of like i don't know that is most
of it most of it is like
he's just and it takes a lot for a guy
like that guy's friends they were like
you could tell they were i'm like was it
funny i just want to know did you think
it was funny like was it funny um
i don't know was it funny and he was
blinking like
yeah he was going crazy and i'm like
okay he started having such a seizure
one of his other friends started filming
it the guy was blinking
and then he took his balls out falls
balls go ahead
so you could tell like i'm like he
doesn't really have a defense he doesn't
want to [ __ ] on his friend
he probably yeah i don't know he they
probably were super annoyed by this
homeless guy which i don't tell
but i think people allow
i think guys are cooler with friends bad
behavior
women yeah i don't i
i i'm a i had to break up with a guy
oh tell me well he just said he didn't
vote in either the last elections
because he didn't see a difference
between
and no biden and
hillary and trump he didn't see the
difference between
no okay good um
[Music]
so so i was just like look man i like
you a lot
you actually broke up i was like i can't
i literally can't do it
i can't do it i did at that moment i
found it so irresponsible i just
i had the thought the other day like i
should bring him back into the fall it's
been probably six weeks so it's not been
like a long time oh
so i know who it is yeah um
you get it yeah i mean what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do when
someone
should absolutely know better and they
do these
kind of like both sides arguments the
both to me when people like i understand
both sides
you're there's no strength in that
you're not more intelligent because you
understand every
i factually understand both sides pick
us up and not pick a side but at some
point in
today's politics especially with trump
i don't you have to pick a side like i
have friends that
well it's not interesting and it's not
it's
it's a cop-out it's like so you can't i
get like hey
man but you don't see that between that
and this
so yeah that's where the courage to
break up because that's
it's hard to say this thing that doesn't
really have to do with you and i
at all in like a daily personal thing
yeah it's
it just has to do with it's not like a
close friend it's just a guy that like i
like
and we're like professional allies and
i'm just like
i gotta say man i can't i got i i
couldn't bring myself
to engage because i found it so
irresponsible
someone that should know better you
couldn't do the
slow fade no because it kept texting me
about something
um so i had to finally go look here's
why i haven't texted you back
um so that's a whole i have a whole
other
conversation i have which is because i'm
doing a thing with
kevin hart about yeah round
cultural stuff i've had to start looking
it's
i have the list i have the mcquarter
list back on here yeah uh
i have to go on more conservative i
don't have to i'm like
kind of listening to more conservative
[ __ ] no i know what's funny is it's you
know the people who watch facebook
videos
that screen facebook videos for uh
content for like violence or degradation
or
they a lot of them become conspiracy
theorists yeah they can't you get like
sucked into it
it's it it reminds me of because in my
head i'm like i don't think i could ever
get addicted to drugs i don't
like anything yeah the way it makes me
nothing
but i don't know if someone put me in a
room and
made me do heroin yeah but you could
figure it out i feel like
it reminds me of that because it's so
manufactured to like suck you in
these both sides are i mean i don't no
no no just this kind of
i don't know it's not like you're only
on like far left websites either you
know
right i'm just new york times which they
would say is the far left right near
times
whatever the place i go if you go to
like right-wing conservative website
there's so
yeah it's hard like it's after a while i
wish it
i wish like how far it was
from kind of the center
is how long it took the website to load
[Laughter]
like this is a 55 second website like
boy you guys are [ __ ]
way out is it affecting you it is not a
no but i've heard some funny there's
always a
how's a lifeline counter that
there's always such an obvious counter
argument that i'm like dude
what you don't here's a great one okay
so i was listening to
there's a there's a podcast called
i want to say what it's called because i
don't want to get hate mail whatever but
they were arguing about how
america's not that racist toward black
people okay so here's their argument
it's a good argument if you don't do
take the next step which is their
argument is
african americans are black people
living in america
are the most successful black people on
earth
they're more successful than anyone in
africa in general
the gdp is higher the standard living's
higher and
technically they're right technically
they're right
but black people are comparing
themselves to white americans
they're americans average fellow
countrymen
which is like you guys don't see why are
you not even bringing that
up right like i'm not going to compare
myself to ir
particularly people that were in brought
here
kidnapped 200 years ago and brought here
they're not going to keep going like
well it's better than nigeria
yeah so not going to complain
but that's interesting for me to just
hear like well what do you how could you
justify this
right and then you hear their argument
you're like
there's no no one's countering this it's
funny though because a lot of their
arguments for
you know the conservative voices
oppressed in the mainstream media and um
voter fraud and steal the election like
let's just give them all those things
that are true you're still doing better
than
almost every white person in the world
so oh
it's just like it's like such a weird of
course well then they bring up like not
finland well why are they doing better
than you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um yeah it's you could do that it's like
well you're doing better than the worst
[ __ ] um it did make me look up
something interesting
what do you think the population of
nigeria is
let's do two stats don't look it up no
yeah population of africa
population of nigeria nigeria is the
biggest cut the most populous country in
africa so i know africa is like
one point something billion okay it's
low once it's
yeah it's just like 1.2 billion
thank you and nigeria
the problem is nigeria has a lot of
people but also the nigerian diaspora is
crazy there's nigerians in every
right but that's there's a reason why
when you're right when you hear the
number of
so i'm wondering why people clutch your
pearls because there's a lot of them
uh uh let's just say 500 million
200 million okay that's a large part
america's 300 million brazil's it's as
big as brazil
ain't no [ __ ] idea in nigeria
or in nigeria world right now so there's
probably 300
there's probably in the world yeah that
i can't speak to
there's so many nigerians but like yeah
pretty great um hold on i've i want to
read
since we're here we'll just do that
since we're here since we're talking
about conservative black
[ __ ] and number stats sorry was that
website
a conservative black sorry was that
podcast conservative black no
they just i i they were they had a bunch
of websites they had a bunch of episodes
and i was like i'll start with racism
okay you know and uh all right so but
john mcward is a guy oh you have it will
all right so john mcwhorter
is a black conservative here's what
makes me laugh about mcwhorter
he has no he doesn't he doesn't filter
himself at all to the point where it's
like
do you have any self-preservation
instinct it's real
i gotta say it's a comic it's like
watching a guy bomb
and not be able to change his act at all
and you're like dude they are
booing you and he does not care
and it's [ __ ] kind of glorious right
um okay so this is back up the the
premise the premise of
the premise of this list is anti-racist
tenants basically and this is
his point is that every anti-racist
tenant
has a secondary tenant that totally
contradicts it
okay the list and beyond most people
that i sent it to
first are like pissed and then you go
which part and you're like i don't know
i just don't like the tone
um i think you fell into that and and
roy and trayvon roy
i won't say what they no i did well okay
so number one
this is what anti-racists preach and
then
also it's and then the other thing that
they preach that totally contradicts it
number one when black people say you
have insulted them
apologize with profound sincerity and
guilt but don't put black people in a
position where you expect them to
forgive you
they've dealt with too much to be
expected to do that
pretty broad that's that to me is like
fine
that's like very wokey this is just like
woke anti-racism
like where if you if you uh
this is i would say the most strident of
the wokes
right you know what i mean this is like
you apologize and i will not forgive you
yeah it's like
most of the time you're not yeah but
it's in the but
what this does it scares the moderates
into thinking this is how this is what
this is what this is like if i don't
follow the okay
uh black people are a conglomeration of
disparate individuals
quote black culture is quote code for
pathological primitive ghetto people but
don't expect black people to assimilate
to white society
norms because black people have a
culture of their own
that one i think he's saying when people
mean like
it's pretty black over there what that
means
usually it means there's a negative
connotation
his second point is not so great no
silence about racism is violence
but elevate the voices of the oppressed
over your own that's a this is a good
one to me
that if you don't say anything you're
suspect but give somebody else a chance
to speak
for you but the problem is and my issue
with
him was not that uh i don't like his
town it was more that i don't like his
i don't like the solutions he's
like he's concluding oh well this is
this is what you have to do
like if this is then this yes so he's
kind of pointing out the contradictions
right if a then b like i don't always
agree with
what he's concluding because to me
sounds about
racism is violence right so if all your
friends
are just dropping n-bombs or something
like maybe you should say something
right but the opposite isn't
um it's like but then some people uh try
to speak about what's going on with
black people
and edge out black people's voices or
just say like oh well now
i'm speaking about awoke thing but not
have any input or not have any
like a black person to say like no no no
like this is actually how it is
and so when you have white people
speaking on black experiences i just
think it's
that but it feels so much less
spicy thing of like yeah it's just like
you have to stand up but also
it's not your place if all of these feel
like you're
a bit of i guess we can't yeah yeah i
can't see anything
nice too i'm not a whereas i feel like
there is
i guess the problem well keep keep keep
reading you must strive eternally to
understand the experiences of black
people but you can never understand what
it is to be black
and if you think you do you're a racist
that's a funny one that was fun
um because it's like yeah that's kind of
true show interest in multiculturalism
but do not
culturally appropriate what is not your
culture is not for you and you may not
try it or do it but if you aren't
nevertheless
interested in it you are a racist
funny support black people creating
their own spaces and stay out of them
but seek to have black friends if you
don't have any you're a racist
and if you claim any they better be good
friends in their private spaces you
aren't allowed in
funny um
when whites move away from black
neighborhoods it's white flight but when
whites move
into black neighborhoods it's
gentrification even when they pay black
residents generously for their houses
uh gentrification's about rental uh if
you're white and only date white people
you're racist but if you're white and
data black person you are if only deep
down
exotifying and other we talked about
that
yeah that one was like we talked about
that we talked about that constantly
it's like if you're dating a black woman
can you masturbate to black
women porn or is that like that's not
what we talk about
every week i did that as a plot i think
on a sitcom one time
on a ticket that didn't get picked up it
wasn't it was that's the reason
no but it's a [ __ ] funny thing like
well i like
what do you mean you like only buy one
yeah
you can't win there uh yeah uh black
people cannot be held accountable for
everything every black person does
but all whites must acknowledge their
personal complicity
in the perfidy throughout the history of
whiteness
funny trueish black students must be
admitted to schools via adjusted grade
and test score standards to ensure a
representative number of them and foster
diversity of views in classrooms
but it is racist to assume a black
student was admitted to a school
via racial preference and racist to
expect him to represent the diverse view
in classroom discussions the he that's
he's talking firsthand right there
he's because they'll bring him in as a
black person he's like oh i'm
conservative and they're like [ __ ]
right he uh you should go on that
podcast
i'm sure he has i just haven't scrolled
back the podcast is called the good
fight
um yeah it's like i get
i get his point i get that there are
these okay
you're making it impossible for white
people to
support you through this weird timer and
because
the hoops they have to jump through are
like who what human being's gonna do
that i get his point but
like i was reading it and i'm like no
it's annoying
like there's so many
i don't know i just wonder because the
problem is
a lot of what he's getting from his very
left very whoa right like he said on the
edge of wokeness
um that's not always like a 35 second
load
on this website by the way this is on
persuasion.com
which is the the website persuasion you
just type in persuasion
dot community and so that's another one
that i'm on
now because i'm i'm uh i'm super
right-wing
and uh because it's so right it's just
it's almost like there's not one you
can't really talk to one person it's
kind of a
it's like like a frankenstein's monster
of wokeness
so no of course it's the most okay
exactly so it's hard to like i totally
get his point and i do think
there is something to be said also some
people make rules
on behalf of black people that black
people didn't ask for of course but he
it sometimes when i read his whole
article it did feel like he was
yelling at black people a little bit
more then he's yelling at a small
audience to me
like a very small audience it's like
okay dude but that's not
but the problem is if that person starts
yelling at you
sorry black people at any woke person
black or white or
any other nationality would be sorry
um i didn't mean nationality i meant
ethnicity or did i mean race
i still don't know um would is afraid to
defend you
to the woke they can't be like look man
yeah
it's just so it's a it's a he's right
and wrong
anyhow what did laurie lightfoot do
oh so basically um there were these
rumors that came out uh lori life with
the mayor of chicago
i'm here in chicago so apparently
there she's not she's becoming like a
lot less and less popular with
uh black people and progressives because
she's not really making good on her
campaign promises but basically there
was
a rumor that happened over the weekend
that said she's resigning
because she was caught in a hotel room
with another woman
and it's like this whole drama that
played out so she responded to it today
saying like it's homophobic and it's
misogynistic lori i didn't ask you what
how to categorize it it's true and uh
she said and so a lot of legitimate like
journalists and
and picked it up and ran out of the
story and she was just very upset
but i think it was i think it's in
combination of how she's
responding to the um what's his name
toledo
yeah adam toledo yeah and
it's just a culmination of people being
very unhappy with her and she's having
to like respond and
i just wonder like
at first i'm like i kind of feel like
being the mayor of chicago is a losing
game
don't do it if you're thinking about
being mayor of chicago nothing is worth
it
nothing's worth it nothing is wrong did
you watch city so real right the doc
i think so it was a doc about chicago
and there was a lot of it was about her
no no no i was really good it's on hula
oh you know what i saw i saw
the one uh i don't know it was one about
we talked about it was the ones that
were like
in the press like that each episode was
a sensationalized story oh yeah and the
blagojevich one
that's when i did not know how deep the
corruption
like duh oh but it's like
stay away from it's crazy but so okay in
the dark
uh humanizer and you just see what it's
like to run
it's the guy who did hoop dreams made a
documentary about kind of
the mayoral race in chicago and also
um just life in chicago yeah
and it's she it's not
just the amount of [ __ ]
gymnasiums you got to go to it's just
like a [ __ ]
just gymnasiums and rec centers and just
like oh
good and when i deep dove into her
and she has she made a lot of campaign
promises that she hasn't really
fulfilled in two years and so
i just feel like chicago has so many
issues complex issues that um
i don't like no
nothing's worth it no i think it's worth
yeah
literally to quote um
the macho man savage nothing means
nothing
uh it just doesn't nothing means nothing
it's let me see that
nothing means nothing um and
so you know yeah just do your best
laurie do your best
but just maybe think about grad school
think about maybe going back to grad
school i think at this point
[ __ ] it i'm sure you get some kind of
deal
something to get go back and get your
graduate degree
be something oh neil
uh so yeah the earthquake keepers i
watched 60 minutes and they all they did
with
they just work with the police the oath
keepers
work with the police they go to black
lives matter rallies they go to protest
and they hold guns they hold guns they
tell the people they wear gloves
a lot of guys in them gloves they have
great glove gloves
a lot of glove work a lot of a lot of
love stocks
um they work with the police
and they the police work with them to
crowd control
at these protests for unarmed right
shootings and black lives matter stuff
like that which i don't understand how
that's legal
oh so the police say no we don't know
about it oh right but then they're like
standing there and
yeah and they're like no we and then
they said a lot of their um
members are like
active military and police yeah and so
and also former yeah and a lot of former
so because and
that guy right there was saying that
because there a lot of former military
and then they're getting police training
yeah they're more
well that's what i'm excited for the
guys to come back from afghanistan
and report directly to the oath keepers
i'm looking
very forward to that to those 3 000 guys
wells banners we'll
spread them out throughout the country
sprinkle yeah we'll do it
you know you saw the map they showed a
oath keepers meeting the biggest chapter
apparently is in arizona
so they showed an oath keepers meeting
and
they're really old mostly retired and
it's
all it is is how to survive
everything yeah like natural disasters
their preppers kind of
yeah they're yeah right they're preppers
they're black
they're prepping for some black invasion
of some kind
it's like literally like flame and then
like there's a black guy in it
there was a black guy in it but he's one
of those old motorcycle black dudes
i was like that guy doesn't have a
motorcycle i'll eat this
backdrop i just the
fact that there's like the milwaukee
mayor that's a motorcycle block
yeah they the fact that they're just so
in with at this like this
it's such a there's such a side there's
such a line in the sand you know
it's just they think they're under
attack i don't have a gun
in my house do you know why because you
have a salt
assault bug assault and i have two
different tasers
i don't have a gun if somebody comes
into my house and be like
come closer no i'm not going to do
anything no
there's a flashlight what are you
talking about cause it's not you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] pay the price
um i don't have a gun in my house
because
i don't think i need a gun do you know
what i mean
just wondering because i don't have
anything to protect i don't it's like
what do you
want i think i've said this on the
podcast
what are tvs worth at this point a
couple hundred
okay that's what i have i have a
computer
that's depreciating by the day what i'm
doing to that computer
although i will say the latest update
hasn't been great so if you're gonna rob
me do it
wait wait a week until i get the new
update
but i just don't have anything to
protect and i don't think
really lies but no one's gonna want to
kill me
i don't think anyone's gonna want to
kill me even
[Music]
if i whatever my profile gets higher
i just don't think anyone's gonna want
to kill me
if you were a woman would you have a gun
and you lived alone
and you were like i definitely have a
bigger taser
you were my strength type like short
hot really
i'm not even looking at you right now
i love seeing you blush um you look very
nice to me by the way
really beautiful really exciting yeah
i mean the better than last week it was
a swamp
i'm kidding um the uh the
i don't uh no i don't i don't know i
don't
i'd be torn if i i i tried talking to my
friends about getting a gun
shamed me i felt terrible afterwards
why would you get a gun what a gun you
know you might
vigilante shoot kids making harmless
videos on the street
so that would be hard for them for them
leave the houseless man alone
yeah the i don't yeah and so you you got
shamed out of it
yeah you got shamed and then you went
and got it anyway well the problem is i
watch this article on like
these like cool mexican gang guns
because they get
they're all like they get them all
customers what they did to bikes
yeah it's literally like the mexican uh
like custom cartel guns
let's take a look look at
that they have any pink
wow look at that this is
more an indictment of women than
mexicans somehow
wait no this is not mexican but they get
you can get them in grains
swirls and so you wanted an art
installation basically yeah a lethal
yeah like a straightforward piece
i guess so
that pink well that's tacky obviously
well didn't see the other ones
um yeah they're lattice they have cool
designs okay
yeah i get it so you would have been
cool like a
maybe maybe get a lighter maybe get a
cigarette lighter
with it's sort of ornate but i hear you
i i if i were a woman i wouldn't rule it
out
i just don't because a guy people do
want to rape you
they don't want to kill me tell me about
it i'm telling you about it
okay i know people no but then i'm like
okay what's my and
my argument to my girlfriend was so if a
guy comes in your house
i mean i'm on the fourth floor so i
can't escape
anyway what if a guy comes in what do
you want me to do
yeah cause one time there was a mouse in
my kitchen i always was like my
neighbors would help me
there was a mouse in my kitchen in the
future when you get the gun you'll shoot
that mouse
i screamed at the top of my lungs for
10 minutes not one person knocked on my
door and asked if i needed help
i unrela after that day i'm like
unreliable don't
wait on your neighbors yeah uh so what
am i supposed to do
i don't know i don't i don't know i
don't i don't think many of my friends
have guns but i
truly don't know i feel like in
california
people wouldn't advertise they had guns
yeah it's not
yeah or if you do you gotta go you know
i'm from the south
eat right my mom's from illinois yeah so
it's part of my culture
oh um yeah i don't know what i would do
uh that's again country with 300 million
people
um 300 million it's a small world 300
million
people as well um bernie madoff
wrestling power king king oh yeah
uh yeah just a funny my favorite
bernie madoff moment
yeah it's he's he's under fire for
bilking like very rich eli
white like holocaust survivor like a lot
of holocaust survivors
oh he built them out of their money
apparently he maybe
got the money back into them i could be
wrong
but um probably not all the money yeah
but um
[Music]
uh recovered more than 14 billion of the
estimated 17.4 billion oh that's good so
that's close
yeah i mean it's like a half billion
until you realize how much a billion
times
until you realize what afghanistan's uh
gdp is and that's
and he he you know but it's a good
economy if one guy
one guy can trick a [ __ ] that much
money out of a bunch of people
anyhow um i so
so madoff's he just got out of jail
and he's walking to his house and will
if you bring this up wait he got out of
jail pushing
he was oh i get it made off pushing uh
photographers
he did a tupac he did a white tupac
um he starts shoving them it's in front
of his house yeah at
home arriving in new york city right
there third down
boom it's great
oh we got the raw footage oh wide
pan down tilt down yeah that's his house
he's not an elaborate house
he starts yeah pushing pushing
get out of my way get out of my way
damn it i just like that he pushed him
let's see it get it
dude anyway there's a better angle where
he's shoving them
and it's so [ __ ] funny to me and you
go oh that guy's a sociopath
i always wondered in the paparazzi
like swarm are you allowed to
they're in your way no uh you can
i you probably have to prove beyond a
shadow of a doubt that you have to go
that way
oh you could just
if you're going to your car door or
something like in there in the way you
have to like
you have to do something i think that's
where you start teasing people
by the way the hunting jacket that
bernie madoff's wearing
yeah if you see a white guy wearing that
hunting jacket in new york city
he's worth bare minimum five million
dollars let's see it
rich bernie made of hunting jack hunting
yes burning
just yeah it ain't a car hard
it's that one oh the the
no no no no the one second one
oh my goodness that is a that guy's
worth five
million dollars mini mom it's like a
burberry quilted yeah
stitched you'll see if you watch the
youtube youtube's growing by the way
thank you youtube people thank you
uh bernie madoff he ripped off holocaust
survivors
and and by the way and he's giving him
two of his son one of his sons committed
suicide
one thing that's what he did and one
died they're both sons gone
yeah he's in this and my wife is living
in west palm
held up at the ex the widow's
house son's widow's ass
i feel no i feel worse for the son's
widow than anyone on earth yeah this
family's
and now i gotta live with your your son
i at least they used to the son
i married him but now i can [ __ ] take
your mom that's why
that's why i don't get married guys you
never know how things are gonna break
people go end of life you want someone
to be there for you but you gotta be
there for them too and that's where it
gets a little dicey
you know the guy who played a poo very
funny today
yes he uh he
made an apology and no one called it an
apology which i think was
a huge oversight he said he wanted to
apologize to every single indian person
for his portrayal of a poo all right
here's my counter argument
okay
neil his that guy's a [ __ ] brilliant
voice actor right yeah like
killer um
the apoo voice was funny of course
it was what do you do with it what do
you do with a funny thing i guess
it's what about the did you watch the
problem with the poo yeah
yeah i thought you know what it did not
dawn on me
as a kid that a poo was
problematic but i feel like i've said on
here
i lived in suburban chicago and suburban
philadelphia
the only indian or pakistani people i
came in
in contact with were at 7-eleven
so it's like is that a smoke box blanket
thank you i i remember that we need to
bring that back oh yeah because we do a
lot
we do a lot of them uh i have a useless
app and uh i don't know what to call it
what is it
just say it it's it's a we're gonna get
it's a
big you're gonna have opinions so i
gotta i gotta we needs his own segment
um it's a kind of a useless observation
um but what do you do if something's
funny i mean i guess
like somebody made the point like amos
and andy's actually funny
it's [ __ ] up but it's fun like a bi
person was like it's [ __ ] funny
but it's [ __ ] up um
so i don't i mean yeah
i what did you get from the documentary
you didn't realize how uh
uncomfortable it made indian americans
watching it a guy named rudy rosh
comedian
who used to host showtime in the apollo
and did warm up for chappelle show used
to a joke about in new york
you're basically refu referred to as the
most
famous member of your
ethnicity so he was like lights if so
he's like if there was a light-skinned
guy they go
or if they if it was a latino guy and
two guys were having an argument they'd
be like
[ __ ] sammy sosa over here oh yeah
yeah like
you just go yeah over here and i pooh
was like the [ __ ]
guy who works at 7-eleven over here
times 50. simpsons was
whoops but so here's the thing that i
thought about
if a poo was voiced by an indian
would it be popular let's say it was the
same amount of popular
would it be a problem would you would it
be equally as problematic
i don't think so the question that i
would ask is
would it have even been anything
if it were voiced by it meaning is part
of the
the the enjoy it's the joke i used to do
about if as soon as you walk away i will
immediately do a disrespectful
impression of your accent like people
like
doing if i have a waiter that's like
british and what
we all know and then we go whoa he when
a waiter
waiters british we walk through example
everyone does india
it goes for everyone every most races
right um
most voices yeah it's
you is that negative representation
um is it if you only have one if
you've got a town with that's basically
a white town or yellow town whatever
i don't [ __ ] it's just it's
complicated but i think part of the
satisfaction
not even satisfaction it's funnier
because
of white guys doing the voice the thing
is most of it like
growing up i didn't know white guy did
the movie no you're absolutely right so
i didn't know either
i mean maybe you did because you i
didn't hang this area i didn't
not when it first i didn't know right so
i don't know if
a poo is funny he says things
differently in a different way than
everybody else but everyone's funny
what's funny about a poo though is he
has almost no
punchlines a pooh's character is like
his
disposition's funny like he's just like
there are 70 billion but like that then
yeah they're indian accents very like
it's such low-hanging fruit but i don't
think there was ever
that china was the joke is the point
right
exactly and there wasn't another indian
character or person on tv really right
so there was a guy in uh the robot movie
oh my god i played did brown face
fisher stevens short circuit was the
movie
i love shorts of course if the white guy
jewish guy
oh he the indian guy not not
indian well i mean it wasn't like
wasn't gandhi played by ben kingsley
killed it okay yeah yeah so
like that one yes uh we just have
ben kingsley hasn't apologized i i hey
that's one of those things where
we demand ben
crushed it but the problem is that it's
fam it's it's popular with kids and so
when
you know i grew up around a lot of
asians and east asians so it wasn't
weird for me but wait he's he's not
indian no
fisher stevens that's that's what we're
giving
what are we giving them indian for short
target
uh i just mean i go around a lot of
middle eastern
people and like asian east asian more
diverse so for me it wasn't
i wouldn't go to an indian person and
say a poo to them right
but i was raising a very specific type
of
city in this country yeah most cities a
lot of cities would go
sammy sauce over here up yeah like we
celebrated earth day
and lunar new year and vietnamese
yeah like it's not a good representation
you agree
you had a little too much representation
and a little too much consideration i
think you're what you're saying
i hear you correctly you're saying give
it a rest
so basically i think that if it was just
a random midwest town just take anywhere
america
it's probably rough for indian kids yeah
and like apu probably gave them
anxiety you know yeah
oh or yes yes i didn't like watching
roots
i i hated watching it and then everyone
made jokes i didn't think it was very
funny
not everyone but the white kids made
jokes well it's like the black kids
were like really that's not funny like
burr used to joke about like [ __ ]
uh ron like he looks like
um richie cunningham
from happy days like yeah [ __ ] black
guys go richie got him and i guess it's
different
because it is black people are not uh
but white people are not oppressed and
it's not the only representation
there's 40 other white people on
television like it is different
i understand both sides oh really
yeah oh really when i
do it i go to a lot of websites a lot of
long loaders um
so i yeah it's
i get it i get it it's just one of those
things where
also the simpsons what was made 1989 was
the first one started in 89 the
[ __ ] up thing are not [ __ ] up it's
like hank is there was like 26 or 27
when the show started like
he's still not that old and he's been on
tv for 33 years
and he's like made so much money for him
oh you can't you literally
he's half the he's out of the town he's
half the town yeah so
he was 25 when it started which is
[ __ ] amazing but that's a good yeah
and he did all he was married to helen
hunt
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah this guy burned
through
some of the greats in this town oh for
one year it was after a twister they
[ __ ] a lot
um yeah but like you don't even get it
um
yeah he does moe he does cheap wiggling
he's coming guys
[Music]
um very talented guy bumblebee man
he didn't apologize for a bumblebee man
what was bumblebee
he
they couldn't find a mexican to do it
now live
on short notice uh
europe there's a soccer thing yeah it
was like there's a i don't understand
european soccer to begin with
basically around 10 to 12
teams are forming their own league
they're but they're i believe they're
staying in their old league and then
there's
going like the premier league yes but
now the premier leagues
are getting mad the premier league my
understanding is
the best teams from all of europe
are in the premier league right and then
every country has
teams national teams are yeah completely
but it's not like the national
i just there's many leagues there's many
how wrong
do you follow soccer football and then
champions league is
europe right okay we were we are
total failures i'm i lived in europe and
i follow you
know the first time hearing of it okay
um excuse me
um so there's like national leagues
obviously but then the premier league
and the champions league are all just
cherry-picked of like the best yes and
then they're doing another cherry
picking
of and of like so is it like to get away
from
wow is it to get away from beef was mad
but i don't know what
oh it's it's the whole thing is vague
they basically have polyamory and
it's like you can't do that to be so
corrupt and weird oh phoebe is the most
one of the most corrupt things on earth
other than other
other uh other ones um
or in terms of organizations it's
there's the only
one that's uh fifa is all the other ones
are
really also corrupt international
organization
uh i don't get it but i think it's funny
and i look forward to the games because
it truly is like the best
no but i might if they're gonna really
they're really editing out the garbage
is this like the xfl it's
it's no it's they can body it's like the
it's messy's team it's all the superstar
team
no i know but what's different about
this soccer nothing
it's just more famous more cuter guys
would you agree with me about this that
if
most women could pick
a body type it would be
the world cup soccer player yeah they're
good
like do you want to see women get a
little quiet watching sports
watch the world cup next time with some
women and they'll get some far away
looks in their eyes
all right when they do close-ups of guys
because the guys are
the guys bodies in particular are not
too
athletic but they're athletic enough and
something about soccer players
they're all ethnically vague right
they're all
something ambiguously ethnic
and they are cute he is so dang
cute ronaldo he's had a
extreme makeover yeah he has he's um but
we don't need to know what he used to
look like
we've got the new ronaldo whatever you
need to do whatever ronaldo and jimmy
carr need to do
is fine with this podcast how about we
don't listen
uh um no soccer players are so smoking
but they are the jocks of europe like i
grew up i grew up i played soccer but
america when american women see them
during the world cup they're like what
who's he but we're like to our soccer
players like
okay actually lafc is that's a fun
staging have you ever been to lafc no
no it might take your favorite thing i
would love that you know you like going
outside
i love driving somewhere that's a nice
that's a good woman's body right there
this is a good body for a body
that's a good body for a lady that's a
lady nope um i'm pointing at me
yep there you go nice and shredded but
not
bulky just like he actually looks like
an exhibit he looks like a exhibit he
looks like the bodies exhibit
another thing where they take the skin
off yeah that's messy
that's messy i'm gonna do a guy version
oh
uh i believe it was it's the in the
olympics
the women's volleyball but latin
countries so like
brazilian women's volleyball okay
look waiting okay we'll go to images
will is really doing great he's doing
great
uh go outdoors better yeah here's my
argument against female there's a good
one
yeah that one here's here's my argument
against
spain go ahead plumper let's go
please spain that's nice right there
that's nice spain that's
nice when y'all when y'all spike in the
ball next
i'm the guy who that wants to [ __ ] him
but doesn't understand the game so what
are y'all
doing spikes and sets next oh i like
that mom
he's stupid oh you which one are you you
the spiker the setter
you all get along or what you all get
along like y'all y'all ever sleep in the
same bed
okay neil what no i'm curious that's a
fan
no um i like the spanish girls
those girls i'll say a little tall oh
you have to be
yeah they're a little tall for for i
think most guys
whereas soccer players are all around 5
10 seemingly soccer players are hot
yeah you know because then you go to
gymnastics but they don't have any boobs
they're like childlike yeah not nice
yeah not in a good way and a little like
like oh she'll
crack my neck with her thighs without
questioning what
you know that like move where they do it
like they you sneak up behind a guy and
snap his neck
yeah female gymnastics like under siege
yes a female gymnast could do that just
her legs the legs coming out snap
you know who's a good body those girls
skaters
ribbon dancers yes the ribbon boo
do you have to go to you have to watch
them though huh
basically ribbon dancers are what guys
see when women are talking most of the
time
it's just like that and i'm like yeah
that's interesting
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
so reverend there's a nice ribbon dancer
in vegas destination fabulous
in the in the on the side that's real
nice right there
yeah oh yeah that looks like x's of
yours thank you vermont
burma thank you um thank you
anyhow oh here's my here's my
come on use this observation whatever i
don't i can't remember the name of the
segments that we do on the show
yes i don't like it
when someone is telling you a story
about their mom
or dad and instead of saying and then my
dad
walked in and said you guys got to get
out of here they go
and then dad walked in and said
you guys got to get out of here it's
like it's not my dad
it's your dad it's not our dad so
clean it up put an eye on it and stop
telling me stories to quote charlie
murphy a little too familiar
it's a little too familiar yes neil
that's always good a little something
for you
well something for you uh here's some
emails
no i don't have any doubts oh i i do i
watch the doc
it's called why did you kill me oh i
wanted to i was
i was falling asleep at nine so i could
wake up at six
like like a [ __ ] farmer seriously
so i watched why did you kill me uh
not a lot of not a lot of heroes in the
dock that's the sad thing about so
it's it's interesting it's like the
catfish
the they catfish gay members to figure
out
who killed someone that's very it's it's
interesting but
uh i don't know what's going on
riverside every
a lot of gang activities would i get
well then monaco and gang activity
okay but all the white people are
behaving little latino it was just very
confusing
what happened so what happens when white
people
find a great culture and we go guess
what
i have a gun can you trick it out for me
and then you've got
an ornate oof like a santa maria
handle and it's pretty special
everyone is doing some
no one has clean hands in the dark but
something tragic happens and it's
interesting how they use
it's also cool because it's during
myspace so it's a real blast from the
past
great um interesting watch is it it's
like also a very quick
easy dock okay but it's not as much of a
dock it almost feels like a
really good date line okay
you know where it's like sometimes i
wonder if netflix isn't doing too many
ducks and i'd say that
i have a vested interest in them making
dots
[Music]
um okay that's it anyhow i didn't watch
any dogs i don't think i
don't gotta [ __ ] get up and worry
about
this is this three percent cash three
percent cash back
on at drug stores cash back at
uh on travel and three percent cash
dragon dining including takeout
um and kevin's holding the card this
time a little more casually
oh a little less carl maldon and a
little more
just super cash by the chest but somehow
he's not covering up his name
and i had to do pickups of that last
thing today
body double we had to shoot his hand
holding the
credit card and not covering up that
the k and the e in case people tune in
late and think
kevin hart stole alvin hart's credit
card a little bit
um emails
some of our look we've got
no we've gotten almost no bad songs no
no no
some work some don't but some work some
don't now who sent him in
eva shot
she's she's she's taken her
finely tuned instrument she's i believe
pointed them at you for one of them
right and here she's got three songs
let's play them one at a time okay
[Music]
that is so that's thank you rethink
thank you song called binky wreathing
is that when i that's you think
something or is that what i read well
if will wants to play it when he thinks
she should re rethink something
and if not that's you know it's funny
she's there's an old man phrase
called it's a women's prerogative to
change her mind
right and she's basically assuming that
you never need to apologize you're just
simply rethinking something
oh because it's a woman's prerogative to
change her mind and even if
she's wrong she's right thank you
great next song please from eva shaw
we don't have to take this [ __ ] no we
don't have to take this [ __ ] oh my god
that's
good my worry is we gotta then blend it
in
the closing song that could be
well that's kind of what how we close
you know what it's like though at the
end of the movie
there's al there's like two songs yeah
yes it's like kendrick will do one and
then
john legend also does one right the like
feel good one yeah
[Music]
[Music]
get we should get john legend to do one
featuring common
uh neil i'm going to leave that up to
you
can you can you actually do could i get
could you actually get james
i mean i have james blake is saying
nobody's mad at you my
the greatest thing i've ever done oh
yeah nobody's mad at you song
james did it live um
and i think john's saying nobody's
maddie because it's chrissy's
favorite song you saw chrissy came back
to twitter why
because she's like i didn't like the
life without twitter
but they're so rude to her i know she'll
uh she's just kind of mute words i don't
know
just mute some words it's anxiety
yeah it feels like music okay um
anyhow thank eva shaw thank you eva
i'm it's so we owe you a debt of
gratitude absolutely
on some radio get around radio
terrestrial radio we now are doing the
anchor the music plus talk show show but
it's all
none of it's all like we own all the way
we own all we own the mess we own that i
like it we own it it's like [ __ ]
somebody sent it in okay okay how neil
phil how pinky thinky thursday listener
here
i am a 25 year old chicano man from the
great state of california
first i just want to say that i feel
personally attacked that you guys don't
have more subscribers like what's going
on
but my question is now that
conservativism is the underdog in
hollywood
do you feel that comedians are hopping
on this conservative train
i hear them talk about liberals like we
are all crybabies disconnected from the
real world
but i come from nothing have nothing and
still pursuing my education and my
dreams
i'm as connected to reality as possible
i think comedians live in the
twitterverse
and hollywood bubble and are the real
crybabies disconnected from reality
except you of course spirit padre
anyways
thoughts feelings concerns thanks for
the show
stay up now and stay brown and beautiful
bianca
gracias uh i know what he means by
it's like the rogan and oh yeah
satellite
people the rogue universe yeah uh i
don't
know how conservative they are
they seem conservative they seem
conservative but i wouldn't
i honestly wouldn't be able to say yeah
like
who voted for trump amongst them like
maybe 20 of them i could be wrong
i don't yeah i don't i think they like
it's more masculine to be like i
i'm a dog guy but it doesn't it's more
macho [ __ ] than it is
political to me yeah but i don't know
like what is it when you guys are like
in green rooms or
hanging out like it doesn't feel that i
don't know i mean i don't
conservative i feel like it's never like
it just feels more masculine
i've never worked i don't know how many
of them are like joe's not
conservative right he really seems
conservative but
i don't think apparently i don't know if
he wasn't going to vote for
biden i don't [ __ ] know but like so i
don't [ __ ] i don't know
i do think though it is you kind of have
to we have to push you in one or the
other
and if you're not
liberal it's like i don't know some
people are can say they're socially
liberal and fiscally conservative and
politically whatever you know what i
think the country should do fiscally
yes i don't know i don't know
what they i have no idea how to run a
[ __ ] 22 trillion dollar
oh but you don't
the gdp that one guy could bilk them out
of
so it's probably not that big anyhow um
but i don't that's the thing i my new
thing is gonna be like
i don't know i have a controversial
opinion about this
i don't know what should happen
pop that's a popular opinion that was
popular
well he cut off so
yeah i don't know i don't know i so i
don't when guys have
big fiscal like economists disagree
so how the [ __ ] you can have an opinion
about something you don't know about
uh but i think the earlier days of
politics
was just differing on how to run the
economy and
obviously identity politics coming away
later yeah so
conservative you're an aggro
mma guy liberal liberal politics offers
them nothing
in terms of identity nothing so they all
have to act like and then who knows how
they vote
yeah but i don't think they have like
immigration
i don't think i don't hear again i don't
really listen podcasts that aren't news
so
yeah same um but i do you think
let's just say comics not specifically
anybody like do you find comics being
more
on the liberal side or on the
conservative side they're
well they're historically liberal
because it's the whole thing is
like right hobbling power
so there's nothing there's not a ton
of great jokes in like
it's kind of like filming a guy having a
tweaking on the street like
ah it's hilarious it's just inhumane
right um if you want to point there's
there's not
no jokes at liberals i have a bunch of
jokes at liberals but
you have a lot you're right but it's
from the end it's like why it sucks to
be liberal it's not
it's just not fun right so if there's
like this
bad boy i'ma say what i want
kind of okay
but you know okay whatever you want to
do
that's how i feel like okay i don't
think you're that conservative but i
but i do agree with you that liberals
are annoying i think that's what it is
liberals are annoying
they don't they don't actually believe
conservative values but they're like
you're offering me
very little yeah that's right that's
good that was good
wrapped it up that's good i really
wrapped it isn't that that was good
okay all right let's do another one see
if i can wrap this one up
hitting your stride thanks um are we
good
is that it oh now we gotta read good
morning this one
okay great this okay good morning great
humans i just wanted to tell you
wonderful people that you are the ryu
and ken at the end of the first street
fighter anime
and the audience is bison
the chemistry is top-notch now combos do
you understand
nope okay um ryuken street fighter
bison is the bad guy do you
watch i don't think you're right ryu and
ken versus bison
oh okay people use the anime
people used to they double team them
yeah they're they're like the back to
back
kind of oh god i gotta get i got it no
no no it's fine
um people used to call me blanca is that
the same
from street he was a he was a brazilian
beast man
i had a five that reminds me of a funny
iowa yeah they'd be like blanca these
kids would come up and like shake my
hand and like please because they're
alone bianca yeah i had a funny
ayahuasca thing where
i was on i was in in in session
and i thought i heard chupacabra in one
of the songs
so then i kept saying i kept thinking
chupacabra and then i started getting
paranoid like
have i called a bad spirit so i have the
shaman come over and i go
hey man uh chupacabra
that mean anything to you he's like it's
like a mexican
deity or did like folk tale thing and i
was like
okay i just wanted to make sure like i
just want to make sure i'm not in
trouble
like anyhow goodbye uh
hi neil and bianca as you know paul
pierce a married man with kid was
fired from espn after he went on ig live
partnering with
partying with strippers and smoking weed
while his firing was expected i found a
slew of people saying that he should
have been fired
and that espn is crazy and wrong for
doing so when i checked who were
defending him it turns out that it's
mostly
it's almost universally black people by
the way i'm filipino and for us his
firing was par for the course
is there something cultural here that
i'm missing
stay safe uh i don't understand why he
was
i feel like his i just
could sue them on his private i guess
that they wanted to get rid of him
anyway
do you know who this person is yeah he's
a former
nba player in fact i uh made fun of him
being stabbed in the face on chappelle
show where i got stabbed in the face
he got stabbed in the face yes at a
nightclub
because it's funny because comedy's
funny uh
he made it that's not the video he made
a video he did an ig
live and um he
uh there were strippers yeah it was just
like low
dumb it was like real like
old guy trying to seem cool right and
it was just like not just a bad luck
just a good old-fashioned bad luck
hold on yeah i you can do it this is
like an obstacle course
okay go yeah keith yeah you got this
go doug yeah yeah yeah this is like a
tough mudder for kate
okay uh it's just bad luck i'm sure they
wanted to get rid of him anyway
and uh is he bad on the show
he's all right i don't think he's great
but i they also
are they all aren't they all kind of
fine yeah the
the problem is inside the nba is so good
oh it is
it's not inside the nba it's on the espn
version
the espn version's just bad compared to
he's so espn it's like dryer it's espn
so it's disney owns them
okay so they feel like just a lot it's
like more
they're they have more of a standard
relationship with the league where it's
like oh like rah-rah
and where's tnt can be like that game
barkley be like that was a bad game
right and they would never sit in an
espn
i i don't know i think he's like fine
and
uh but it i don't understand why they
would sue them if weeds legal
may they sued him no fire them i'll fire
him yeah but
i don't i don't know they probably have
some social media clauses or something
yeah
it was just that guys trying to it's
like dog
that's done that part of your life's
over or you don't need to film it i
don't [ __ ] know
it just looks good but they just want to
like i want to be on ig live and it's
like
you pull up just yell and pull up at
different people um wait so
the more interesting story how what
happened he got stabbed in the face
yeah he was just like apparently it was
bad i
didn't it was always sort of like
they didn't there wasn't a lot of
information and then they said
that uh once i knew more about it
he was stabbed 11 times in the face 11
times in the face yeah
um yeah so
oh my he must have terrible ptsd
and panic attacks yeah i feel that's one
of those ones where i'm like ah
that maybe we rewrite that
um but we just didn't know like no one
knew he was [ __ ] up by it was just
like ah that [ __ ] got seven i
love how you guys are like
he's fine well we didn't know panic
attacks and pediatrics like nothing just
like i don't know we played
like september yeah i don't think he was
like
watching the night i'm sure his eyes
were closed or squinted he wasn't like
what a knife let me get him i don't know
that i don't know
i guess i don't i wasn't at the club um
so i don't know uh it was par the black
people were defending them because black
people
uh naturally defend black people because
uh they historically been picked on
and uh uh
abused by white people when they didn't
do anything wrong so
even if they did do something wrong the
instinct is to protect before
they ask questions which is a very
nice feature of black people
um it's a feature shared by all black
people based on that list
goodbye uh but i can never understand it
hello
i love the podcast and medium term
lstner
okay i'm a thursday youtube watcher and
that's almost a tuesday listener status
almost
but not quite i'm from california moved
to the bible belt to be a cop for a
couple years qualified immunity
is necessary to prevent the trump-esque
personalities from further causing the
law enforcement from disproportionately
impacting the poor of course i mean
further impacting the poor
right now if a cop is doing their job
lawfully and gets sued the case usually
gets kicked
without qualified immunity any rich or
litigious person could financially ruin
any cop
this is a thing i'd never thought of
yeah and i the first paragraph was like
[ __ ] this guy and then i was like
oh so if they they could just any
person can sue any cop you'll and ruin
them and this the guy who makes
80 grand or 100 grand a year but why
can't there be a similar system to what
happens with
uh medical professionals and doctors
where you have to buy your own
malpractice insurance
yeah i mean you know you have to buy and
but at least it gives some
accountability because
we we've we've worked it out with
you know anesthesiologists with like
it's high insurance but if you're going
to
be a cop in a certain area i mean you
know should the county pay
obviously maybe they're premiums
i if i'm i'm not gonna they don't make
enough money
to have to pay for insurance on top of
their how to take it out of their salary
do you know what i mean like and then
you're basically back to qualified
immunity well
if if if if there's a way that the
premiums weren't
insane but it's almost like you're
responsible for your
right premiums aren't going to be the
premiums are going to be insane because
anyone can sue them at any time then how
how does it work with
doctors i'm not they have to sign a [ __ ]
everyone they deal with how to sign a
shitload of
everybody liability waivers right so
do they pay for their own insurance yeah
i believe they do
i know private practice they obviously
do sure but i mean like if you work for
a hospital
or like a city i'm sure they have to pay
the friends yet this is one of these
things where you hear this you go oh
this i'm the mayor of chicago all of a
sudden and i don't know how to solve
this
life you can't stop it uh and then he
goes on to say that he
abhors the uh acts of violence against
people who look like me but anyone who
ca
by anyone who carries a badge the
solution to changing police culture is
partly to diversify
police departments but that would
require getting people into the idea of
joining
also police departments control many
aspects of their hiring process
even when they work with their city
someone can put their thumb on the
scales for or against someone and there
will never be a non-vague
and there will be a non-vague reason
given
oh there will never be a non-vague
reason given this guy over outdid
himself
with the double negative uh i was good
cop
didn't mind the low pay and wild aspects
of the job when i couldn't be there for
a once in a lifetime fame when i
couldn't be there for a
once-in-a-lifetime family event for
non-specific reasons
i was done uh now i still get a low pay
or vague rejection but at least i get
to be there for family stuff this guy's
an actor is what he's saying
but but i the first point i'm surprised
that cop listens
slightly i mean it takes one hell of a
cop
he's a former cop he's an actor he's
trying to he
he thinks i'll hire him um but that's
the thing i mean i go back to camden i'm
like
okay fine don't take off quality i don't
know how they did it you're
the mayor she's the mayor of camden i'm
the mayor of chicago welcome to how neal
field
um oh longy yes
this is a long answer i'm not gonna
there's a better this about
exterminating all brutes funnily enough
recommended it to a buddy of mine and he
was like kind of was like dude it was
too heavy
it was my buddy mark starberry best
known for writing
you guessed it when they see us too
heavy for the guy when they see us but
that
is there's something we said about our
point last time which is
sometimes yeah i don't know he's like he
said
and he listened so i hope he doesn't
feel like i'm betraying him but he said
there's [ __ ] you know without knowing
you know it
he's saying it's that shit's in my body
already oh no 100 percent but there is
when you see
the like yeah i think
the 800 hands when you see a yeah a
bucket of hands not great
the 800 year 800 stuff
when it just goes back and back not like
i have to defend its worth but it's
it was like ah
it's not easy and he said i was like
yeah i go sorry man and he's like
and he's like no i'm glad i watched it
but it's just
i think everybody should watch the first
episode and then
and then you don't you don't have to
watch like that it's epis it's similar
episodes
you get so much it's drinking from a
fire hose i tell you that
you need a second yes so um
get through one oh okay so this is a guy
this is a so this is a is this a guy
negative response
to our discussion of white brutality in
light of
exterminator birds okay his subject line
was white violence discussion was
incredibly [ __ ]
oh then he wrote hope that dumbass
subject line
gets this red so binky and spirit
podrick's discussion of european skull
shapes unrivaled capacity for violence
brutality
was objectively absurd the idea that
past
imperial projects around the world
weren't bloodthirsty and expansionist
is definite uh definitively false here's
a quick
list of expansionist empires that
decimated everything in their path
so then he sends a list of empires now
then he said human beings are the apex
predator on a ruthlessly violent planet
take a look at our chimp cousins social
structures and capacity for violence and
war
they're insanely brutal and we won the
evolutionary war against them
so what does that say about us the
mayans literally played soccer with
freshly decapitated heads
that seemed like hearsay uh the islamic
empires were extremely jingoistic that's
how islam became the second largest
religion on earth
the ming dynasty in china is known to
have been one of the most brutal violent
societies
ever assembled genghis khan killed 10 of
the population on the planet
stalin killed tens of millions uh
yeah he's not wrong no the
i guess my the thing that i would
counter with is like
the magna carta and
human rights weren't really a thing
until the post-enlightenment values
are pretty new and in that time
there's things that um there's been uh
in that time there's been a
lot of colonialism that should have been
like well if you guys believe this then
you shouldn't do that and they're like
well
if it's black people they're not there's
the enlightenment doesn't apply to them
right so i don't know that's my counter
but he's not wrong
he's not wrong but let's just because he
said the
uh conversation was ridiculous but if we
go just on this side of things so let's
not go back in history let's
at this point in in where we are in the
world
white people and like let's just say
white supremacy not necessarily white
people but the idea of white supremacy
is in every continent
of of the world i mean there is a white
supremacy issue
in asia there is a white supremacy issue
in i think in asia it's more cosmetic
literally it's it's it's more cosmetic
obviously but it's not it still
represents i mean here it's cosmetic too
right
yeah but here it's legislation here it's
treatment
no in asia it's total treatment i mean
it's almost like cat system and age but
they don't
have any other well india has a cancer
yes of course
which was a big problem against us no
but that was put in by the british that
wasn't
naturally occurring in india so that's i
i i totally get where he's coming from
but to say like
ridiculous it's a little extreme like
there's enough
examples of what we're saying he used
the r word
[ __ ] um ridiculous disgusting
yeah so to me i'm like you're so
appalling i don't understand how you can
be how can you be so appalled when
you're just offering counter art you're
offering more information to our point
we were saying that we're not he's
offering counter
he's our he's making it a human problem
right
and there are plenty of examples now
that is human yeah right
it's chinese are putting uyghurs in
concentration camps it's not white
supremacy no but we talked
but what i'm saying we talked about that
last time like the way certain like
there's like in africa there is a lot of
different like
like in nigeria like colonial yes
but there are and there's plenty of
intramural problems
yeah uh that white people have nothing
to do with
totally yeah but i don't i it's
impossible to
i don't know the i don't know but which
one has the most
impact on the entire globe i mean that's
kind of what it is and i'm not saying
aggregate currently i would say it's
or let's say the last hundred years yeah
let's if this guy right back
he wrote regards so right back and after
saying you're disgusting no and let us
know
like let's go the last hundred years
yeah and let us know what if you think
the last 10 years that white people have
been the problem now they may just be
because they're on top and whoever's on
top
is you know is brutal right
no and that's fine but i do think that
when you're on top and
there's a ripple effect of all the
things that come with this particular
person being on top
i think if the chinese look i want him
to know if we were doing
this podcast when genghis khan was
around
we would say that the chinese we'd be
calling out names i mean
okay corrupt style so
think about it goodbye goodbye
goodbye okay you've got mail what a
carrot i mean you want to talk about it
this is not a karen video it's not a
caller i know but
if you you can't believe it
i was shouting in my car listening to
the wow
show today i'm a day late it's on
wednesday
trying to say that intelligence is not a
protected class
and so there is an iq limit upper
limit to become a police officer because
of the attrition rate of people
who have higher iqs so neil is correct
that both evolved people do not want to
do that job but the evolved people who
did want to do that job in the past
got out very quickly once they got in
and now evolved intelligent people
are not permitted to become police
officers i love your guys show i love it
so much
i i look forward to it all the time
thank you thank you thank you
and i like that she was screaming but i
don't
i kind of don't know why she was
screaming just to just to agree
but i don't think there's a limit on
intelligent people becoming cops
no she's saying that like uh well
she said like they're not allowed to
become cops but i is there some sort of
i mean i don't know the process fully to
become a cop so i don't know if
i think just show up but but the
beat cop just the regular cut like if
you have
a a degree they probably give you a
different job
that i don't know i don't know if
there's like office or candidate school
like there is in the military but i
don't think they're not allowed to be
cops i just think they would be
highly probably like pushed like do you
really want to do that job don't you
want to
be the tim once you've around when
you're asking mayor
um uh okay goodbye you've got this guy
wants
this guy goes off on ronnie chang my
friend ronnie chang for his netflix
special
why would ronnie do i don't know he's
trying to he's going like
i watched it i didn't laugh once oh
that's hilarious and then it's like oh
so you my permission to drag your peers
um as two people who's around comedy all
the time what do you think is the lowest
threshold of good jokes for you to find
a comedian funny
or to put in another way what ratio of
good jokes do you
need to keep watching with interest one
in five one in ten
or is this an impossible question uh
ronnie's [ __ ] very funny
you know okay but it does we get asked
this kind of all the time oh yeah it's
fine ronnie's [ __ ] hilarious
can you look up ronnie chang just so i
can see his face um
he's on the daily show i want to see
oh yeah um how did you like his special
his special was [ __ ] hilarious he's a
very funny guy i mean
how it my barometer is always
uh subject and level of difficulty
so as ian edwards said it's not that
hard to write original jokes just
talk about [ __ ] people aren't talking
about
which is easy which is it's easier to do
that
right but what do you do in a funny way
but it
it that that's a higher level of
difficulty if you can make a joke about
a thing that people don't
i remember somebody was like did you see
uh i think it was like laura bates is
her name
um laura bites lore bites i was way off
and uh they're like you've seen laura
bites bit about clams or
like something and that's just like
that's how it works like yeah
you made a good bit about cl i don't
remember what it wasn't clamps but it
wasn't no
i'm scared and then it becomes like so
that gets
points if you can have a good bit about
something that nobody has a bit about
that high level
yeah and if you can do a bit about some
something that everyone has a bit about
that you have a
the best version of that's also
like a thing yeah it's all you kind of
uh
it's almost like when the in
exterminating all the roots when they're
uh just
they're like oh i found this island bam
like if you're the first person that
could
yes get that like you will now be
referred to like
oh that's like brennan's joke about or
neil's joke about joke about yeah
whatever so that's it's that and then
just
like what's at the originality point of
view
like it's like it has to be
interesting it like it's not you don't
have to all it can't all be
you know uh williams yeah where it's
just like
i'm dying overlapping the whole time i
can still enjoy all types but
it has to be interesting like on the off
when you're setting up or
like there has to be interest because
some it's like
a lot of talk or it's a lot of story i
don't know there's different types
though
like it's impossible to answer this
question but it's the
level difficulty is basically point of
originality
and kind of rareness i have a comedy
question
no what's the what's the type of format
that you're not good at like you know
some people can't do punchlines some
people can't do long story
long form some people can't do
um like can you do a jeslik style
yeah some of those are that oh yeah
you're good at that
like he does like macabre one-liners um
uh or jimmy kind of similar is there one
that you're like i know i
am not i'm not gonna um
there's not one no i don't know like i
don't really do i do act outs but
you wouldn't think like i don't move
much
i try to move but it's not like like i
don't have much
need to move like it's not like so i go
into the store and i open the thing and
i
it's like i just don't my jokes aren't
the i did i did a thing and this
happened to me right
it's like did you see what those people
were doing
you don't yell a lot no i don't
but i'm louder than you'd guess
yeah that's true but you don't do much
at all yelling
yeah i don't scream like you gotta added
like innocent or whatever
no i don't think i i don't think my
voice could
you can't scream there's act what i you
could scream
not really not like directed at me
um and if i did you had it coming you
did it to yourself to quote the great
philosopher that guy on the street
goodbye
and this is gonna be a long one um
i'm a 27 year old black male about to
start my last year in
the wake of george floyd's death and
other police brutality
events in the past year many of my
classmates were posting pretty ignorant
things online
clearly did not understand the blm music
movement or
history of these kinds of events uh i am
the only black person in the class of 48
with more than
half b being a majority mormon
white people and the other half
split between asian and hispanic uh i
along with a
dominican girl and an asian girl in my
class decided to start a
dei diversity in equity and inclusion
club
so we can have open dialogue about
current events
and people can learn more if they choose
to most meetings went well
but a solid amount of our more
conservative classmates have asked to
meet with me
more one-on-one and talk rather than
meet together all i do is talk to them
about my experiences things they should
watch exterminate all the brutes been
recommended and what they can do to help
i'm not a conservative by any means
but i do have more relaxed demeanor and
maybe they feel more comfortable that
way
the girls on the other hand while very
intelligent consistently play the blame
white people game
with just about everything you know who
plays that bianca last week one of them
called out a student in our class
group chat for white privilege for
getting a grant that the entire class
got
and said he had quote a fragile white
ego
for getting offended by it he's pretty
good guy as far as i know while i
thought it was funny at the time it
definitely dug most of the white people
in the class
deeper into their stance and now they're
on the defensive
i told the girl that said that privately
that she probably just sabotaged her
goal of educating these people and she
was really offended by it
this girl i love this club the girls
think i am too nice for talking to them
one-on-one and that since i'm a man that
is
why they feel comfortable uh it seems
they just want to yell at white people
every meeting
and to me this gets nothing done what
should i do uh i want to have the girls
backs but they while out sometimes and i
really feel like they're killing our
whole club
at the same time there's only a few
months left before we hit
the next phase and i will never see most
of them again until graduation sorry the
longest letter
what does spirit padre enslave mirage
madrid
that's very funny hey bleep out what
kind of school he's in
because i don't want to be a dead
giveaway
um uh well i don't know what you can do
but i think there's a lesson here in
persuasion
which is just you're just gonna you're
just gonna make
white people [ __ ] defensive it's that
thing i was saying like
you're in a black people are in an
abusive relationship
with a malignant narcissist and you have
to approach it as such
with like compliments sandwiches and
you're doing great but has it ever
occurred to you
and then also i think
women the women that are it's like hey
come to this school white people club i
mean the problem is the
the club from jump one hilarious two
if you're gonna start a club about
diversity equity and inclusion in the
demographics that you're working with
like
you are gonna have to give some of your
energy to
trying to get people to understand what
you're talking about if it's asian and
hispanic
half asian and hispanic and half white
that seems all right no no i mean like
a lot of the conservatives wanted to
come right
and not being met with uh
you know as like warm of a welcome so
i'm just wondering
i don't think it's anybody's job to like
whatever you don't have to educate these
people but they seem to want to go out
of their way to like
try to promote diversity inclusion i
actually disagree i think it is your job
to educate people and i don't say that
juggling
no i don't think you can present a
problem and then go i don't know how you
deal with it
but i think that's boiling that's not
exactly what's happening
yeah no i agree but that's a it's a
separate argument it's a separate
argument i just think
that i it's not my job to
i think you can talk about whatever you
want to talk about and you can hand
and you can take on whatever you
can like you don't you don't owe anybody
giving the class
no outside of this club what do you
think their responsibility is
in the club well that's my point if
you're going to start this club that's
why i said i don't think look you don't
have to go and
convince these people i've had endlessly
like i went to college do you have any
conversations i've had where i have
done it got down in the dirt with people
and been like no this that no this is a
thing
so thank you goddess of callbacks i've
uh i've um especially i mean i was in
oh i won't tell you well that ages me
i've been in europe
i've been back and forth in europe for a
long
time and i've had to i've had to heed a
lot of
ignorant questions and i it takes a lot
out of you
after yeah a long time so i'm that's my
point
don't start a club don't start a club so
these people want to start a club okay
so that's a different situation if
you're going to start a club
then you know the problem is a lot of
people want to start a club but a lot of
they don't want to start club if you
know what i mean
um to me if you're gonna start that kind
of club
when half the people are conservative
mormon white and
it's college they probably do want to
engage in some sort of discourse
yeah you have to be a little bit
you're taking you you gotta you gotta
meet them you can't
you literally have to like guide them
you have to meet and and be incredibly
gentle you have to meet them where they
are
i will say mormons are some of the
nicest white people i've ever met
i'm not even kidding the mormons i've
met there's white people everywhere
no but mormons are a special kind of
special event
yeah thank you so i do wonder about the
girls that want this club
and these people are coming to the club
and do want to have discourse
and there's intolerance on both sides
somebody told me a quote
from the rapper david banner who's now
like baby
he said everybody
most people don't want to solve the
problem they just want to hold the whip
which is like these women are holding
the whip like they get to [ __ ]
flagellate white people
and it's while it's incredibly
satisfying and cathartic i'm sure
cathartic everything nothing bad um
they should be paying for that yeah like
not yeah like not
not uh what's your bottom line
that's kind of what it is is your bottom
line to
like just basically tell them how wrong
they are okay
but they maybe don't start yet like it's
not gonna be the most popular club
you're gonna you're you don't need to
unfold as many chairs next week
because it's gonna be a tournament
um no i mean look i have so many far
left
like crazy left liberal friends i'm from
i'm not going to tell you where i'm from
but
you get it so and i'm oh i feel
conservative when i talk
like we just what i
what is so then you start thinking okay
well what's everyone's bottom line
is your bottom line to have a space a
safe space
away from white people so you can
complain about why people find then do
that
right but if you're going to have
also they should they should film this
talk about filming i would watch it
you would watch it yeah it's but it's
too late to film it
well i just mean also white people
aren't going on record talking about i'm
i'm the only one who's dumb enough to i
know shut up about it
[ __ ] give it a rat do yourself a
favor for once
neil drop it um
you've got mail hey neil bianca i
noticed lately that some gender binary
people on twitter have started putting
he him his
and she her in their bio can we put them
in the trying too hard hall of fame
or is this just another case of people
wanting to leave and label themselves
something
sorry for the short email love the show
sorry but please don't
um uh
i you know how i feel about this i think
it's
a very small group of people it's like
we the
doors are doors we all deal with
are uh six
feet and six feet
six that's about how tall a door is i'm
not exactly sure but it's around
and when blake goes to malls he has to
walk through and
tilt his neck to the side and that's
just what happens because he's in
he's an outlier if you're an outlier
that's just what happens there's
inconveniences
that you deal with i would suggest my
belief is
80 inches that's six i don't know how
many feet that six
eight six eight so guys that are six
eight
some guys that are oversea how tall is
blaze over six six you gotta do
something you gotta you're gonna watch
your head
how tall is blake griffin i think he's
six nine
there you go um six nine
yes um you're an idiot if you haven't
slept with them already
you're a [ __ ] idiot you're because
you have them
you had them right there dm them damn
come on anyhow uh
i the him i just don't think that the
non-conforming gender stuff is a big
enough thing that
people that are conforming need to
identify themselves as conforming
and i'm sure that someone will use this
video to
bury me but i just think it's a small
amount of people now and again all my
thing is i believe in civil rights
we have your civil rights but me
labeling on myself him
him his or whatever he him is
unnecessary it's just unnecessary um i'm
trying to
shake off my blake what yeah you're
picturing you like
i had him um so uh
also the remember our friend to the show
the trans
woman said that
just ask someone their pronouns
i don't want to i don't want to have to
ask every single person i make their
pronouns
hmm sorry i just i don't it's like
saying what did
you know what it's honestly i just think
it's like if you're not
if if when we meet go hey i'm
my name call me she
do you know what i mean like it's on
them to tell you and not
for you i think so yeah i mean again i
don't but even that's like a civil
rights
problem by going you tell me i'll do it
but i don't i think most people are
gender conforming
most men who look like men are he him
his and most women that look like women
are uh she whatever and then there's
some people that are not if you're not
that then tell me
yeah i guess it's or is it weird if they
just is it because
if you were saying she to me i'm like oh
my pronouns actually he
him he is would you like mob
or would you be like okay cool yeah you
hear that you get a load of this one
everybody come over here no i would
absolutely
what do i care right so it'd be like it
would be a non-issue
it wouldn't even yes wouldn't there's a
comic at the store who transitioned
talk to her i no i think i
follow her on twitter one of the things
we've never really interacted but not i
didn't really interact with him as a
man and i didn't it's just not in you
it's just i don't know it's
don't see her very much so but i'm not
mad i'm not gonna make a point of saying
him like i know
it's just so like yeah it's not i don't
i don't that's not how i
i don't identify myself
in opposition to your gender
names i'm not like under no circumstance
and that's who i
am i don't i don't care right i'll just
do whatever you need me to do but
i don't think every single person should
have to ask every single person on earth
do you feel like a man in my body
yeah in your head i've thought that's a
good question and it's none of your
business
come on uh yeah yeah i've never
had the thought i'm a woman because i
because i was reading something the
other day where it
it's that's very difficult
yeah oh i was on one of my websites i
was on one of my loaders
i was on a long loader and there was a
there's
this is where it becomes all legislation
it's a famous case
in in the in the trans community uh
british
man this is like math
british woman sorry
i think sh born a woman 10 years old
is suicidal depressed and wants to
change
her gendered to man
the national health services only
their protocol is like if someone asks
you do it you give them
puberty blockers and you give them uh in
this case male hormones
basically now that the the
became a woman that became a man i don't
remember
i think became a woman okay no became a
man
sorry so jesus was born born a woman
becomes a man
through um surgery and
uh medication yeah and
then realizes around the age of 20
something that i didn't want to be
a man i was just depressed
sues the national health services for
negligence for not
teasing that out of
him
yeah and i think one but this is one of
those things where like
this is complicated this is mayor of
chicago [ __ ]
honestly where you just go i don't
[ __ ] know i don't know
chicago because yeah cause then it's
you're denying
yes if you if you if the if the the
policy is we don't care what you think
you
are then that's a problem
and it's also a problem if you go what
do you think you are great we'll make it
happen
and then it turns out you didn't ask me
enough questions or whatever
right if i'm if that's why
prince philip died i heard because
because of the case like he was like
[ __ ] this
and if you're the king you can you're a
prince you can speak directly to god
because that's how it works
um this guy will do
one more goodbye and then yeah we really
don't have to take the [ __ ]
so much that we have two different songs
about it
that's the short one i hope this letter
finds you well neely feel him bianca
delfilo
hi i'm a dedicated lsdr tuesday morning
acolyte here's my tail here's my tail
i nearly died today oh no during these
wacky times i've decided to quit the
auditioning and bartending and learn the
family business
so i've been driving around with my
brothers and father a lot more
uh sounds like a nightmare to me sir
this morning we had to get up early for
a meeting
you lost me again my brother and i were
in his truck
again i'm lost on the highway when we
felt
uh what we had was a flat tire my
brother was luckily already driving on
the right-hand
lane and uh uh
was able to signal before pulling onto
the shoulder that's when things got
weird
turns out the back right wheel had
popped off completely
the truck drove over its own wheel and
smashed down onto the ground
this guy's this is this is these guys
doing the ribbon
routine right here they've been dancing
yes i got out of the vehicle to
see the tire rolling down the highway
for a brief moment i thought about
grabbing it off the road but it was
heading
into the middle lane and there was
pretty heavy early morning traffic i
held back and looking back i'm glad i
did
my running out of the highway would have
caused even more danger my question is
this
am i dead inside while this was all
going on i don't remember feeling any
panic or fear
i don't remember feeling anything other
than the effects of adrenaline
uh it all happened quickly but it may as
well have happened
on netflix for as much as it moved me i
should mention that i've been in therapy
for a number of years and i have pretty
problematic childhood
uh i don't know my feelers should i try
mother aya
what about streaming half-baked my
apartment on loot for the next 48 hours
i'd love some advice
love the show thanks for making it uh
and no one was hurt
um i think sometimes you don't
feel fear i was once in a car accident
in high school
and i just kind of like um
one time at dave's apartment
we'll go 95 he
was uh
i believe [ __ ] and
some incense we used to burn a lot of
incense back in those days
uh started a fire
on his on his uh
radiator like cover thing in new york
and i
said uh dave we have a bit of a fire
which he thought was he mentioned for a
long time
and but i just wasn't i'd like knew i
could
it could be put out and it wasn't
so sometimes you get like and other
times you're like
i see how this can end right like pretty
peacefully and that's one of those
things where you see a tire
and you go ah
yeah you're not dead inside and it's not
like a bouncing
[Music]
like rivet that can break through
something i mean it could it could
damage people ensure
thousands of people die every year from
[ __ ] like this yeah
but sometimes [ __ ] just doesn't seem
that scary
yeah and i think that's one of them i
think you're right
um it reminds me of another tire and
dave story
tell me here we go
night before we start shooting the first
season spell show
i had i ordered us electric scooters
off of the internet this is you've been
ordering scooters for
decades bianca i haven't changed a bit
i ordered one and then
i ordered him one oh
um yes this is uh where are they now
dumb purchase
um i
put it together it was pretty it was
like very you know when you open a box i
think i've talked about this before and
it smells very chinese
yes there you go this was manufactured
in china
without a doubt this smells like this is
a box of china
right and it was uh so it was it was
very little assembly required
yes anyhow long story short we're riding
riding like rough riders uh on our
little scooters
our little 30-pound scooters and dave's
in front of me
and i just see him immediately go over
the [ __ ]
immediately go over the handlebars and
uh he i
he broke something but just didn't get
it looked at
because like we had to film what
the next day okay um and it sounds like
i set them up
basically the front tire i just didn't
screw on tightly enough
and it was like i it was like there was
a
separate piece or a separate piece in
high school we read it like where
a kid did something [ __ ] up to like
yeah
um but the tire rolled
so far it was hilarious
like he broke went over the tires
broke his something like shoulder
something
and uh
the tire went like half a new york block
down
and then onto the sidewalk and down into
like
where people throw the trash away in
that building
it was so [ __ ] funny how far it went
um and that's my runaway tire story guys
and you got a little chappelle show
anecdote
and a little a little uh a little a
little
where are they done i think it was
around 230 bucks
those scooters uh it's funny that this
is a tire story or not
i basically that's a tight story
sweetheart make no mistake this entire
story
or or it's neil trying to force
chappelle show into everything
like you know he died he said silent
audience you know
um all right um if there was a song that
i was gonna play right now
gosh
[Music]
ha ha ha ha ha goodbye ha ha